[Music]
it reverse home alone news so your home
Oh a lot of people the kids hunting the
adults the kid left to New York and the
parents they just major houses
packed like a Filipino home my for
grandma's 16 cousins or a Mexican home
literally any minority any minority I
miss living with roommates oh no you
don't says that you really do be
relatable you really do miss living with
roommates like a punch out that mess but
their energy yeah cuz well I have really
cool roommates that's well that's why
yeah I call downstairs
they have chili made thank you Bob sure
he's a [ __ ] prick he eats our chili
submitted by Gio needs more lovin it was
proven before that even was said a 12
year old stole his mother's credit card
and flew to Bali for a vacation
tell your Cupid to Bali I've been the
bomb I guess the ethnicity Balinese he's
Balinese no it's uh Indonesian Indonesia
and who else have you guys ever stolen
any money okay never never I put money
in my mama's purse yeah I did but it was
changes quarters I would steal you're a
hooligan you know did you pay her back
never will you pay her back please no
Dan I stole 40 bucks with my mom I could
never in my heart ever ever steal my
purse
did you do it for crack no it was a
fifth grade you know my child that's
been really restricted to watch TV I
never listen to any music and all that
stuff huh
so I just felt super left out with my
friends and everyone had a Walkman and I
was like that's the only thing I want
but I can't even listen to music so I
was like [ __ ] I don't have money either
and I was like [ __ ] it I'm gonna steal
that [ __ ] so I bought I stole money from
my mom and then I bought a Walkman and
then I only had the Montell Jordan
cassette tape the one was like
that's pretty good is that alright
alright
who was the song to listen to over and
over again it's justified in my that
might be the best $40 it's ever been
smashing how she found and [ __ ]
trashed my [ __ ]
did she [ __ ] let me ask you this why
did you steal from your mother when you
could have stolen from the store I
wasn't tall enough to so I went to a it
was a safe fonts no now known as rite
aid and it was all the Walkman robbed
behind the counter because people like
you yeah no I just I couldn't really
reach I thought about that I thought
about that I would have stole from the
store before I stole from a parent
integrity the only the only store that I
had access to because of my bicycle
transportation was write it or save on
you never heard of begi have you have
you met his parents he beg for his
parent on freaking their birthday I'd
better get off my knees so I could go
watch TV all right [ __ ] annoying
though dude I think I could out beg the
[ __ ] out of your mom mom your mom's
strong but she hasn't met me
she's really shy you ever really met his
mom so you're taking it so seriously my
beggary beggary I beg the [ __ ] out of my
parents to get my way
[ __ ] so annoying in the middle of
night knock while they're sleeping oh I
got it yeah can I get can I get a bike
night I [ __ ] don't stop if I want it
I'm gonna get it did you get everything
you want it I thought you wanted like a
car and you never got it never got no I
don't know I never get [ __ ] that I want
it but yeah it's just a big flame you're
begging doesn't negate it
I still get I still get it I just don't
get the thing that I want cuz they're if
they had the money they would do it
because I had big dreams I was like I
want the [ __ ] leg old pirate ship set
the big one and I would you gonna do God
they got me a lego thing but it was like
the pirate small one like a little
caramel phenom and I have big dreams you
know I don't know if that show work
because I was begging for normal [ __ ]
like can I get Chips Ahoy please I just
want some regular a snack
I never like snow right yeah that's why
you had to beg big and then you can yes
you're a good negotiator
that's like Trump you know he begs me
yeah yeah eyeballs everything yeah then
he just gets the normal [ __ ] you guys
wanted to guess where this kid was from
any more guesses
I just heard in Tunisia that was it
Somalia America I think when you go to
Bali is like yeah not that Germans
Bobby's pretty tired right
well yeah also he's 12 though yeah so he
must know that this is a paradise place
hmm
he's Maldivian he's Australian
Australian oh okay that's close enough
that's billion kid what is he doing now
is he in trouble and a lot of trouble
with his parents I'm sure so what he did
was this kid who's being named as drew
but apparently doesn't made-up name it's
not Australian at all so this kid from
Sydney he got in a fight with his mom
stole her credit card
[ __ ] you Mary I pictured him
uppercutting his mom and then digging
into a purse like a crackhead does he
have the gloves with the cutoff
fingertips leather gloves oh I just put
them on I just put them on in my
imagination yeah what color black always
black yeah well with the ruffles I mean
there's like red ones and white - oh
yeah she knows those are tight no sir
shows I know [ __ ] - okay no [ __ ] like
he's part of the streets yeah they're
covered is very pointless gloves because
like you know you can't really commit
crime because of the fingertip and then
it exposes all the most vital areas like
you don't want your knuckles cut and to
me those gloves make you look like
you're about to jerk a dick off what
kind of game are you watching all of the
good ones
it sounds really you know glove hand job
so I recommend it action yeah so drew he
got his mom's credit card booked a
flight to Bali and he booked the hotel
and everything so apparently his family
goes there often for family vacation oh
so he knows around
he's been there he knew the resort to
stay at yeah exactly made the trip I
couldn't stop him at that boy was gone
for four days
oh [ __ ] no one stopped it like no one
even asked about his parents or anything
until he got to Bali and then finally
like someone asks like where's your mom
and all he said was like oh she's back
over there and that was it like they
left him alone at 40 I can see that
working loca is my first trip alone to
Taiwan is most
but don't they assign you like a
specific give you a little batch thing
yeah but if you're 10 and you're Asian
kit you look six I'm assuming this guy's
white so your pilot looks 18 but at
least four when I used to go to Mexico
my mom would go to the ticket gate
people and then she would get a pass and
she would actually walk me to the gate
but now it's different because like we
can just check in like at home via email
this kid smart so he knew that he was
trying to avoid anyone asking him about
where his parents were or anything so he
did as much as he could online he
prepped everything yeah he prepped
everything cuz he was able to convince
his grandma to give him his passport oh
he like you can convince your
grandparents to do it sounds like a
Frank William Abagnale dude like to
catch me if you can kid like he's got
the he's got that street smart yeah yeah
he does cuz he got away with it for this
long whether the parents have the
program has how the passport is so
depends what did that conversation sell
my face hey I knew my password for what
my parents though are ready to spoil a
little sure it's true my passport
grandma she's never able to get people
to serve him beer what stop motorcycle
without a license exactly the cab is
amazing yeah well he piloted the plane
to Bali right defend 8,000 Australian
dollars which equals to about six
thousand 115 US dollar fall on his mom's
card in Bali he lived like a [ __ ]
Emperor then because you can crush it in
Mali like you can stretch a dollar as
far as I've seen in August this kid's
gonna go places like I see a lot of
potential well either a criminal like a
hardened criminal or a very successful
jail then FBI yeah right because that's
what they do that they recruit you
there's a criminal Secret Service type
or a businessman or gigolo
well why gigolo well because he he got
this lavish vacation without having to
pay out of his own pocket
oh that's what you know but jiggle is
not the [ __ ] though yeah I mean he if
you wanna know I read some article is
win
like yeah gigolos and they're saying
most of their clients they never even
[ __ ] them they just like women just want
oh you're reading some articles about
male dude wills yeah my readers [ __ ]
anyhow were you just like you just on
some particular website from your gigolo
stuff yeah that's cool you know just
checking it out anyway yeah so this kid
actually got away with it all
that's true cuz if you're really rich
it's like dick is everywhere think what
else what can you you don't need to be
rich to have dick everywhere hello yeah
dick sorry what do you mean rich yeah
we're like quality dick core like we do
like really good like you still get
pretty quality data for poor girls don't
even like quality didn't like what he
did
no what does that mean girls like dicks
that are alcoholics riding motorcycles
like treat them like [ __ ]
girls like those things are nice bits
finish last
Oh while women like quality dicks girls
I guess like the [ __ ] up dicks women
hate quality this hey how you're married
with the child and [ __ ] I don't know
Kardashian's was he well he proved this
point right okay would you say that you
have forwarded it unbelievable the more
you trash me the more you prove my way
which is a win-win check me mofo
are you proud that you're diggin
qualities no I'm just happy I check
mated you where the more you talk [ __ ]
about me the more you prove my point you
have to compliment me yeah in order to
disprove me yeah checkmate mama like a
couple than you I suck and so do my
choices
proud you're so proud of your on quality
dick right yeah for you man thank you
dude only on the bottom
mmm-hmm no all of it off I okay so the
parents were rushing to Bali to pick up
their son I would not rush [ __ ] that kid
they just know they just don't want to
spending more money like they just
called the credit card freeze they
should hire like fake kidnappers and do
that whole let's go [ __ ] out of them
get the real one sorry down six jeez man
you know they don't want to lose what
500 more bucks that's it
Indonesian kidnappers are cheap oh
that's true in Bali it would be pretty
cheap fruit they'd probably do it for
real yeah when I just like hire them for
real like kidnapping back tossed yeah
they probably have a real kid that was
there so this kid had to go through
Perth to get to Bali and so the parents
had to do the same and the parents were
stopped in Perth because that same
airline company that the kid took
stopped the parents and said you can't
take this flight because you don't have
a return ticket home and they're like
what the [ __ ] you let my twelve-year-old
go with no one we're trying to go over
there and catch our kid he was wearing a
very adult hat miss look like you had a
return ticket I liked how they always
defend themselves no matter what you're
like hey you [ __ ] up on my thing like
sir this is actually the regular way
airline policy that's so funny
[Music]